so there have been so many celebrities
getting divorced recently but here are
some celebrities you might not have
known got married this year Simone biles
got married to Jonathan Owens in April
and they met on Ria in 2020 beanie felin
married Bonnie chance Roberts in June
and they were together for four years
before this Lucas Gage and Chris applon
got married in April seemingly after
only a few months of dating and at the
end of January it was reported that
Abigail Brin married IRA keninsky and
they had been dating for 6 years before
this Colton Underwood married Jordan C
Brown and May and they had been together
for 2 years before this John Ham and
Anna Oola got married in June CA married
Dan Bernard in May Naomi Watts and Billy
crudup got married in June and they've
been together for six years before and
in March Ben Savage married Tessa
angerme